all right now straight out of this line
i want to draw your attention to
the remainder theorem okay which you
actually did a bit of work with
yesterday but just in case you can't
remember what the actual theorem is
come back to that zero right this guy
over here
okay if i take that 0 and i sub it into
this polynomial okay so if i work out p
of 2 because of the way we've written
the division transformation right
you can see that this is going to become
2 minus 2 and it doesn't matter whatever
you get you'll get some enormous number
right but it's going to be zero times
that okay so you're going to get zero
here
and then what you're left with is this
independent term
right so it's just going to be minus 27.
so in other words okay when you take the
zero
of the divisor okay and you sub it into
your original polynomial
what you end up with is the remainder
and that's why this is called the
remainder theorem
okay so let's generalize it suppose we
were not dividing by x minus two
okay but suppose we were divided by some
linear harmonic factor like so okay x
minus a
right therefore in such cases
if i take the zero right and sum it in
that's going to be equal to r right
namely the remainder
when your original polynomial
is divided by whatever that factor was
okay make sense now if this is the
remainder theorem
the factor theorem which is what the
second exercise you're looking at
yesterday
is just a special case of the remainder
theorem namely
when the remainder is zero right okay so
if i'm taking
this and i'm saying okay what's the
factor theorem
it means that if i do this thing i stick
in that that number which in this case
was
2 right
if i stick in that number and what i end
up with is 0
okay that means that the remainder is 0.
okay
so instead of saying the remainder of
this is zero
i would use that language which we
introduced back in the terminology right
which is to say that this is not just
any old divisor it's an actual
factor hence factor theorem right
so if this is true
then x minus a is a factor
factor
okay so you've actually already done
a whole bunch of exercises with this
okay but just to give a trivial example
right suppose you've got this guy
now i know you can factorize already
that's kind of my point in choosing it
but
because you can see if i take something
like say p of
minus two okay that's going to be
four plus five times
minus two plus six which is ten minus
ten
which is zero okay so this is the way
that you would go about
solving well actually factorizing first
and then going ahead and solving a
polynomial okay
since p of e minus two is zero therefore
and you don't have to write this but i'm
just going to try and make the
connection okay
by the factor theorem
x plus two is a factor which you already
knew right
okay now once you know that you've got a
factor then you can divide through and
you can get the rest of the factors okay
i know in this case you don't need to
but if it's a cubic then it's a little
more helpful because there's no formula
there that's going to
get all the factors out in a nice quick
way okay there is a formula
but it's not nice or quick it's really
disgusting